وفقا للتحقيق توفي في ظروف غامضة
بعد عام. وبقي سؤال ثلاثي. اين
التي تتاجر بها كانت مجوهرات
صينية ذات نوعية رديئة وكان
ويختفون كالاشباح. انهم ضباط
المخابرات الروسية سريون. عاشوا
القبعات السوداء جواسيس خطيرون.
يظهرون على طريقة دراما نتفليكس
هؤلاء الجواسيس جنود الظلام في
الوقت الحالي ادوارا مختلفة في
متخفين في الغرب لسنوات بسير
ذاتية مبنية بشكل متقن ومندمجين
معروفا ايضا انها تزوجت في عام
الفين واثني عشر في ايطاليا برجل
وامريكا بشباكه بل انه يستخدم
اليوم رجال الظلام واصحاب
الاثنين ينتميان الى المخابرات
الروسية. عندها قامت ريفيرا
واحدة من مئات الجواسيس الذين
وظفهم بوتين ليضرب بهم اعماق
بقوة في مجتمعات البلدان التي
يتجسسون عليها. وكان العشرات من
ذهبت الجاسوسة اولجا كلوبوفا
الان? هل ظفرت بمعلومات سرية
خوفا من الكشف عن هويتها بسبب
التشابه بين رقم جواز سفرها ورقم
تبرر رحلاتها انها مرتبطة بعملها
كمصممة مجوهرات. لكن المجوهرات
الغرب. منها اختراق السياسية
والتلاعب بالانتخابات والتسلل
مهمة? وما مدى خطورتها? خفايا
حرب التجسس البوتينية? ريفيرا
واغرائها الايقاع بضباط من
ايطاليا وبلجيكا والمانيا
يطل بها الامر كثيرا ليتضح امرها
وسحرها الماكر. فبعد يوم من نشر
الغرب وامريكا اذ انه لم يكتفي
بجاسوساته الفاتنات ليوقع الغرب
الشرق الاوسط وجنوب شرق اسيا.
والتقطت صورا مع الزعماء وكانت
والسياسيين في شبابها. اختفاء
مفاجئ. يبدو ان شيطنة بوتين لم
جواز سفر المشتبه بالتسميم. بعد
شهر من مغادرتها ايطاليا. نشرت
هؤلاء الجواسيس نشطاء ايضا في
العهد السوفيتي السابق. ويلعب
مالطا اليوم في تقرير قالت فيه
ان ماريا اديلا كانت ارملة دون
الجنسية من روسيا والاكوادور.
لكنهما انفصلا بعد فترة وجيزة
تحقيق تم فيه الكشف عن تفاصيل
مشبوهة حول جواز السفر الذي
مارشيليس ميث رئيس تحرير طباعة
مجلة كوزمو بوليتان في بريطانيا
القصص كانت اكاذيب اخترعتها
اديلا لتوقع اعضاء الناتو
بسبب اصابتها بالسرطان وقالت حان
الوقت لكشف الحقيقة. الشعر ينمو
لكني قادرة على التنفس. في
السنوات التي زعم انها عملت فيها
بشراء تذكرة طائرة من نابولي الى
موسكو لان مشغليها امروا بالعودة
وسط علاقة صعبة مع والدتها
بالتبني ووالدها ولكن كل هذه
تدوينة باللغة الايطالية على
فيسبوك زعمت فيها انها اختفت
الان بعد العلاج الكيميائي قصير
جدا لكنه موجود. افتقد كل شيء
استخدمه احد عملاء الاستخبارات
الروسي الذي قام بتسميم العميل
ذكر شيء عن زوجها الميت. اما
القصة التي روت ادلل للاخرين عن
وتلقت الام رسالة طارئة من بيروت
تسألها العودة بسرعة فتركتها لدى
وثمانين الى الاتحاد السوفيتي
لحضور الالعاب الاوليمبية بموسكو
الروسي سيرجي سكريبال تم الربط
بين العميل وماريا وتم التوصل ان
عائلة سوفيتية صديقة لترعاها ولم
تعد مطلقا فنشأت اديلا في روسيا
سابقا والتقت به صيف الفين وعشرة
بالجزيرة وهو ما ذكرته صحيفة
الجميع فهم مصدر اموالها. كان
لها متجر وتغير سكنها بين ارقى
حياتها انها سافرت في صغرها رفقة
والدتها عام الف وتسعمائة
بدأ مردود المداخيل بالانخفاض
فاستغرب قال لم افهم لماذا ستفعل
شقق المدينة من دون مصادر دخل
موثوق لكنها استطاعت بجمالها
علاقاتها الدولية ستعطي بريقا
ونشاطا للنادي. بداية القصة.
بين الفين وتسعة حتى الفين واحد
عشر في مالطا وصادقت اشخاصا مثل
والولايات المتحدة. ان اولجا
حقيقية الروسية سكنت وتعلمت ما
ولتلعب الدور بشكل احترافي.
افتتحت نابولي متجرا للمجوهرات.
لاجوباتريا وساعد عضو بارز في
النادي بالدخول اليه. ظنا منه ان
ذلك. رواية ماري ادلة عن حياتها
كانت مموهة وغير واضحة صعب على
في الحصول على وظيفة سكرتيرة
للفرع المحلي لمنظمة الدولية
بعد ان اقامت علاقات مع اغلبهم
واخذت معلومات خطيرة لم يستطع
احد الوصول اليها. قال ضابط
الماني ان ماريا اديلا نشطت جدا
في الفين وثمانية عشر واستعدت
لدفع رسوم العضوية للجميع حين
التي تعمل على تحسين نوعية
الحياة في مما سهل عليها الاتصال
عشر سنوات صداقات مع عاملين في
قيادة القوات المشتركة للحلفاء
بافراد الناتو والتغلغل فيهم
بشكل اعمق فتواصلت مع مسؤوليه
وامتلكت ملهى ليليا وقادت حياة
اجتماعية مفعمة بالحيوية ونجحت
والاسطول الامريكي السادس.
استخدمت اولجا كلوبوفاس ماريا
اديلا كوفيد تريفيرا مودعت انها
ابنة باب الماني وام بيروفية وفي
اسود نابولي مونتون ويفو لبناء
علاقات مع عسكري قاعدة
كعميل سري عاشت حياة نشطة على
الشبكات الاجتماعية سافرت الى
الاستخبارات العسكرية الروسية.
في الجنوب الايطالي وتحديدا
التالية سافرت بين روما ومالطا
وباريس حتى استقرت عام الفين
الاعضاء والسياسيين والجنرالات
شيطنة بوتين الاخطر على الاطلاق
التي اعمت عيون الناتو بجمالها
وفتنتها اولجا كلوبوفا جاسوسة
بمجال المجوهرات لتضع قدما
الدوائر الاجتماعية بقاعدة مهمة
وثلاثة عشر في نابولي حيث يقع
مقر الناتو. استخدمت عضوية نادي
لحلف الناتو ولجمالها واثارتها
واجادتها ست لغات كونت على مدار
ناشطة بمجال المجوهرات وتجيد ست
لغات. استطاعت بالجنس والمال
عام الفين بدأت في استخدام اسم
ماريا ريفيرا وفي السنوات
نابولي نجحت فاتنة روسية بانتحال
شخصية مؤثرة مجتمعية وناشطة
على اوتار الاثارة والجمال.
امرأة لا تقاوم قنبلة الجنس
والاثارة جاسوسة فاتنة ليست كاي
جاسوسة ساحرة مثيرة رشيقة وجميلة
اختراق اعماق الناتو وامريكا
اسقطت بسحرها ونعومة اظافرها
الى شبكات الكمبيوتر للحكومات
الغربية واختراق انظمة حساسة